et nous en parlons avec gilles godefroy
bourget jenna yang chercheur en droit à
l'université de toulouse bonjour et
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france est-ce que selon vous les
élections vont pouvoir se tenir ce
dimanche
oui je remercie madame la journaliste
quelle que soit l'issue de la crise qui
cristallise la rubrique centraficaine
nous invitons nos compatriotes à la
tenue de ces élections parce que le fait
qu'aujourd'hui les élections ne puissent
pas avoir lieu
ça veut dire que nous voulons rhdp
données en légitimant notamment
l'instabilité politique et cristallise
la république centrafricaine et raison
pour laquelle la position de la france
déjà en dénonçant ce putsch manqué et le
fait aujourd'hui
les etats unis demandent à ce que qui a
une transparence électorale
ça veut dire que manifestement la
communauté internationale soutient
aujourd'hui le processus électoral en
cours selon vous quel rôle joue
précisément la france dans ce dossier
centrafricain aujourd'hui la france
était toujours partenaire de la reprise
sont en fidèle depuis l'existence de la
reprographie call et a eu beaucoup des
choses qui sont passés en route ils sont
en finale et qui vit également les
acteurs de la crise centrafricaine qui
trouve l'issue de la solution qui
gangrène la réflexion trafic de vie si
longtemps la france a pris une position
que nous nous avons salué le fait que
déjà condamné cette tentative de coup
d'état qui a été manqué récemment ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la france veut
devenir un acteur majeur dans le
processus électoral en cours comme elle
a été toujours dans le passé alors des
renforts ont été envoyés dans le pays
par le rwanda et la russie est ce que
vous comprenez que l'envoi de renforts
russes notamment pose question à
washington qui demande vous l'évoquez de
la transparence à la russie vous savez
la crise sont africaines après deux
dimensions dirigeants politiques assez
assez très diversifié le rôle
du rwanda aujourd'hui à une explication
d'ordre géostratégique le rôle notamment
de la russie a également un impact jo
politique le jeu stratégique et le fait
qu'aujourd'hui les états unis demandent
une transparence électorale tout en
sachant que le partenaire de la rubrique
centraficaine partenaires traditionnels
que la france prenne position
donc voyez notamment les avions de
chasse pour contrôler ou sécuriser le
processus électoral
ça veut dire que la reprise
centrafricaine est devenu un acteur
majeur de la politique internationale
non seulement ça y'a une une une
question de death d'une et deux autres
qui arrivent à caractériser la
trajectoire de la crise centrafricaine
mais tout ce que nous savons nous savons
qu aujourd'hui ce qui replace le peuple
le peuple demande est d'aller aux urnes
c'est à dire ne pas aller au jaune sert
petto pédaler dans l'illégalité
constitutionnelle et c'est ce que nous
avons tous droit dénoncé avec force et
avec abnégation et on l'a vu ces
derniers jours le scrutin est perturbé
par des groupes armés qui est derrière
ces groupes armés en centrafrique
effectivement la question qu'il faut
poser aujourd'hui nous sommes
aujourd'hui entouré par des pays comme
le tchad et les deux soudan et la crise
centrafricaine le c'est cela l'objet des
vélos des autorités centrafricaines de
la société civile et des acteurs majeurs
de la crise centrafricaine qui
n'arrivent pas par faux-pas d'indexer
les pays voisins comme le tchad et le
soudan qui se mêlent dans le processus
de la déstabilisation de la rapide
centrafricaine maintenant la réponse
apportée par rapport à cet effet c'est
quoi est ce que le tchad a une part de
responsabilité par rapport aux derniers
foyers de tension que nous venons de
connaître
il faut maintenant établir la
responsabilité des uns et des autres
nous voulons également aussi lui poser
la question aux pays partenaires comme
toulouse ou donc qui est proche
est ce qu'il ya une bise ont mis en
cause des deux soudan qui ont pu
notamment par rapport aux derniers
foyers de tension que l'artiste on
confie qu'elle vient de connaître
merci d'avoir un
répondu à notre invitation au godefroy
goojie edge à l'eeie chercheur en droit
à l'université de toulouse